[Alkış]
Evet sesim geliyor mu geliyor galiba 20
dakika sürem var o yüzden hemen
başlayacağım herkese merhaba bugün Ne
anlatacağım size
sunumumuzda başlayalım Bugün size bu
dayılar haklı mı sokakta sizi
çevirdiklerinde çıkar göster o telefonu
diyen dayılar haklı mı değil mi Bunu
anlatacağım size dayılar versus gençler
çıkar göster telefonunu
konuşmasıyla karşınızdayım şimdi dayılar
haklımız konuşmasının Aslında temelinde
şu var Biz kuşaklar arasında çatışma
yaşarken bu gençleri bu Büyükler nasıl
tanıyacaklar bu kavga nasıl çözülecek
kulda Biz Öğretmenlerle müdürlerle
patron Nasıl anlaşacağız anlaşabilecek
miyiz bunu Anlatmaya çalışacağım size
şimdi dayılar haklı mı acaba
çık söylemiyor Çünkü birçok dayı bunu
söylüyor yani tek Dayı söylese dersiniz
ki ya bu adamın meselesi ama sokakta
böyle defalarca birkaç tane dayı ya
tamam çıkar Göster şu telefonunu hayatım
Bak müthiş diyorsun burada bir sosyoloji
var Bunu bir anlamak lazım gençler de
Buna tepki gösteriyorlarsa onu da
anlamak lazım haydi birlikte anlayalım
Neymiş o fark nereden çıkıyor bu
kavga son dönemde şeyi çok
duymuşsunuzdur işte Z kuşağı geliyor Z
kuşağı bomba gibi bunlardan bir cacık
olmaz diye cümleleri çok duymuşsunuzdur
Kimisi der ki size bu isim de neymiş
kendimize niye isim veriyorsunuz diye
eleştiririz Şimdi burada sosyoloji
reddedemeyiz Bakın bu kuşakların farkını
müzikler üzerinden
Şaş arasında doğduysanız aramızda yok
herhalde Şu anda o orada Doğanlar var mı
bilmiyorum şöyle bir göz gezdireyim
Herhalde yok
45 ile 60 arasında doğduysanız Başka
şarkılar söylüyorsunuz mesela
Siz yani Neşet
Ertaş Bir Türkiye iki dakikada gider
Çamardı çalar Yani hemen girmez onu
çünkü
radyo var
mecbursun dinlemeye Bugün 2 dakika
şarkının introsu olsa hemen spotify'da
şak diye değiştirirsiniz şarkıyı
iki dakika giriş yapamaz başka
türkülerine bakın
yakıyorlar arkadaşlar
çiçeğe böceğe doğaya Yeşil Başlı Gövel
Ördek Turnam yare selam söyle Telli
Turnam bizim ele varırsan şeker söyle
kaymak söyle bal söyle Kara tren gecikir
belki hiç gelmez niye böyle yapıyorlar
çünkü telefon yok Kara Tren Ne haber
gönderecek telli turnayla haber
gönderecek arkadaşlar telefon yok bir
şarkı ona yazılıyor yine başka bir şarkı
biçimi Burada mesela
Mona Roza diye bir şiir var değil mi
maalesef Kızlar size Mona Roza şiiri
yazılmayacak
o kadar değerli olmadığınızdan değil ama
o zaman Mona rozadan bir tane vardı
İşte Hendek İşte Deve şarkısında Barış
Manço diyor ki kuyu başına vardım
Zeynep'i gören diye nasıl haberin
aldıysa Dayı emmi hep orada şimdi kuyu
başına varmış Zeynep'i gören diye
Zeynep'e aşık olmuş Çünkü Zeynep kız bir
kişi onu görmüş sadece başka kimse yok
geçti aşık oldum Niye bu kız Çünkü o
zaman bir taneydi çok azdı bir şey
aslında değeri artar bugün senden çok
var Instagram'a girdiğinizde slaytla
bakın aşık olma biçimi değişir
Burası arasında
yani aşkına şiiri değişir dönüşür
şimdi bu insanlar
1945'te 50'de doğan insanlar
tarım alanlarından şehre müthiş fakirlik
yaşıyorlar buralara geldiler Güngören'e
geldiler Ümraniye'ye geldiler
Sultanbeyli'ye geldiler ağır fakirlik
yaşıyorlar bu insanlar evlenemiyorlar bu
insanlar işte köyde rahatsızlıkla
evlenirken şehirde evlenemiyorlar köyde
rahatlıkla ev sahibi iken şehirde ev
bulamıyorlar ve ne oluyor büyük acılar
çekiyorlar şarkılara bakın lütfen şimdi
bu
şarkılar 1 mi görelim bakın
Orhan Gencebay doğum tarihine bakın 1944
Batsın Bu Dünya diyor Müslüm Gürses 1953
ne diyor Ustam
Böyle Yaşamaktan Bıktım Ben Usta diyor
Başka Selda Bağcan Adaletin Bu Mu Dünya
ne yer verdin ne mal dünya kötülerinsin
Sen Dünya
yorum
u diyor Adamın sesi bile acı Yani aynı
dile gelir defol git kapımdan diye yani
Ben de bu dağların nesine geldim yani
her hali acı adamın devam Zülfü Livaneli
Ey Özgürlük diyor tamam mı Hep
adaletsizlik şarkıları yazıyor Cem
Karaca ustam geldi sırtıma vurdu unut
dedi romanları İşçisin sen işçi kal giy
dedi tulumları şimdi bu dönemin
şarkılarına bak birden neye
dönüş 90'ları bütün şarkılar değişiyor
ekonomi değişiyor Çünkü Türkiye çok
kanallı televizyonlara geçiyor Türkiye
Gümrük birliğine giriyor serbest pazara
giriyor yani şu dönem değiştikçe ekonomi
değiştikçe teknoloji değiştikçe inanma
biçimi şarkı söyleme biçimi değişir
arkadaşlar buranın şarkıları ne oldu
biliyor musunuz bandıra bandıra beni hiç
doyamazsın tadıma bütün numaraları ben
sende var beni farkıma Sakın başka yerde
olmama Sakın başka yerde vardır tadıma
yakalarsam öperim
karabiberim Serdar Ortaç bir kızın
göbeğinden zeytin yedi Bütün Türkiye'yi
izledik böyle yani kahvaltı yaptı
kız hepsi senin mi Ah Söylesene 1970'te
kız hepsi senin mi diye şarkı ama
90'larda söylendi Çünkü Çağ değişti
bakın kuşakların isimlerini Boş verin x
y z zamanı ruhu diye bir şey vardır o
Zamanın Ruhu inanç biçimi eğlenme biçimi
evlenme biçimi değişir dönüşür Buraya
geldiğinde ne oldu
2000'lere geldiğimizde sizin yaşadığınız
döneme geldiğinizde hız çağı başladı 300
tane şeyi aynı anda
yakmak neyini doğru Ben tuttum sonbahar
yaprak miktarı geri geldi mi dostuma
Selam Olsun Gökhan ben ya gel
gel gel gel hadi bana bırak beni bu
nasıl bir gün kalsın Bir gün varsın
bilgin olsun Aa ne yapıyorsun manyak
niye böyle şarkı söylüyor tamam mı ha
kapalı radyomuz da çalıyor yine de niye
böyle çünkü
acısını
buradakiler çekiyoruz artık buranın
acıları başka burada aynı anda 300 şeye
yetişmeniz lazım
burada böyle bir şey yoktu 90'lı
yıllarda en fazla atari'ye giderdiniz
aynı anda 200 şey
yapmak zor Neden şimdi 3 tane gençleri
anlam Ak için size
büyük sorundan bahsedeceğim bu
jenerasyonun anlamak için yani o
dayıların anlamadığı dayıların şaştığı
durumu Anlatmaya çalışacağım Şimdi size
şimdi Birinci sorunu gençlerin bolluk
paradoksu 5 Şubat diye bir adam var
ted'de yaptı çok ünlü bir konuşmada ve
kitabı da varsın diyor ki bakın
Keşke ile
birlikte Ah tatmin duyarsınız yani bir
şey çoksa çok fazla
çikolata Şuraya bak
tığımızda Ben hep şu gerilimi yaşıyorum
acaba hangisi
daha sıcaklık değil Çünkü ben ne
yapacaktım sevmiyorum yani siyah
çikolata sevmiyorum ve bu çikolata önüme
her geldiğinde strese giriyorum
Tamam Çünkü bir tane hakkım var ya ayıp
edip 3 tane alamam yani belediye
başkanının odasına gittik ikram ettiler
3-4 tane çikolata adama bak
sınlar
onu ne demek bakın bundan 10 yıl önce
bundan 30 yıl önce alabileceğiniz
ayakkabıların limiti var 3-4 marka
30 yıl önce alabileceğiniz arabalarında
okuyacağınız
tütünün geçtiğinin en büyük sorunu Neyi
seçeceğim hangisi kitap hangi makyaj
malzemesi hangi kıyafet hangi araba o
kadar çok seçenek var ki seçemiyorsunuz
bir buçuğunluğunuz bu akşam
arkadaşlığınızda film izleyelim
dediğinizde seçmeniz bir buçuk saat
sürüyor doğru mu
seçemiyorsunuz bile o yüzden de
influencerlar var Yani insanlar diyorlar
ya bunlara Ne iş var ihtiyacımız var
çünkü sen paran yok fakirsin
40 tane makyaj malzemesini deneyemezsin
o zaman deneyen biri var Bak bunun eyle
aynını bilmem ne bunun işte burası
kayıyorsa bir daha anlatıyor sana bunu
Aa benim de zaten gözümde işte sivilce
var Onu da sivilce varmış Bak bunu iyi
geliyormuş diyorsun sen kendini o yüzden
arkadaşlar
bolluk para dokusundan çıkmamız için
birden influ ısırırlara etkileyicilere
ihtiyaç duyduk o kişi dedi ki bak
okumanız Gereken 5 kitap yapmanız
gereken üç şey zıplamanız gereken 3
bilmem ne 10 adımda 11 adım nasıl atılır
falan gibi o sebeple Mesela bu dönem
gençlerle ilgili bir çözüm mü getirmek
istiyorsunuz mentor ve koç
yetiştirmelisiniz gençlerin hiçbir
dönemde olmayan kadar yol göstericiye
ihtiyacı var öğretmenlere ihtiyacı var
Öğretmenlerin her birinin artık bir
influencer olması gerekiyor bütün
gençlik çalışanların influencerlar çünkü
bu yönlendirebilmesi gerekiyor
tavşan deliği çıkması Şimdi bundan yine
25 yıl önce burada benimle yakın
yaşlarda olan hocalarım var onlar bir
ders çalışırken dikkatlerini dağıtan şey
sayısı 3'tü at hadi Televizyon ki o da
belli saatlerde izleyebilecekleri şeyler
var atari televizyon ve Sokak sizin
dikkatinizi dağıtacak şey ise sayısı 300
Siz YouTube'a girdiğiniz anda şöyle bir
şey oluyor YouTube'a girdiğiniz bir
konuyu araştıracaksınız elim Cansever
işte Yerçekimi yazdınız yan tarafta
YouTube size şey öneriyor Çünkü herkes
her iki kişi
bıçak bıçakla öyle yani çabuk soğudu
Ramiz Dayı bir tıklıyorsun Allah girdim
bir tavşan dediğin Hadise Harikalar
diyarındaki o tavşan diline girdim
Oradan sonra bir dehlizdesin ve kendini
neyle buluyorsun mesela Ramiz Dayı tüm
sahneler Sherlock öldü mü hangi Sherlock
daha iyi İlber Ortaylı komik sahneler
Kızılderililer Türk mü Lady dayana nasıl
öldü
Evet kim Britanya nasıl kuruldu Cesur
Yürek meşhur sahneye motivasyon
konuşmaları 21 günde hayatında işte
bunları asla yapma Mutlaka izle aha
Sen Edip Can seni de araştırmaya
girmiştin nerede çıktı
tünel Mahmut hocanın odasına çıktı
bambaşka bir yerde şu anda şimdi o
sebeple bakın yine büyüklerin gençlerle
ilgili anlamadığı şey bu Çok fazla veri
var ve çok fazla dikkat dağıtıcı var
bütün şirketler bu gençlerin dikkatini
dağıtmak için çalışıyor her pazartesi
günü oturuyorlar nasıl Bizim firmaya
Reklamını tıklar da gelir de burada
babet alır
için binlerce kişi
[Müzik]
milyonumuz gelsin arkadaşlar aynı şu
filmde olduğu gibi hemen görelim
heyecanlandılar heyecanlandı Evet 2
saniye basmayın
her şey geri al bir şey ee
Bakın şimdi durduralım
ders çalışmaya çalışıyorsunuz bakın
karşınıza neler geliyor Instagram'dan
Twitter'dan WhatsApp'tan bunları da
şöyle bilin
WhatsApp Telegram Facebook işte Google
ve TikTok Tamam şu tipler bakalım
görelim neyle karşılaşacaksınız oğlum
bir sayalım
1314 1.315 1316 1.310 yani 1318
[Kahkaha]
Kafanı karıştırmak gibi olmasın ama
apartmanda alacakmış
400 liralık
[Müzik]
bu karılar gerek yok konuşuyorlar Senin
kafan karışacak
sayende karıştı
şimdi bu jenerasyonun en büyük sorunu
sürekli mesaj alması onu yap bunu yap
buraya git şunu yap o yüzden gençler
yetişemiyorlar ve üçüncü büyük sorunları
ortaya çıkıyor burada sunuma dönelim
üçüncü çok büyük sorun ortaya çıkıyor
burada o da şu sizin hayatınızda o kadar
fazla mesaj geliyor
ki siz kaçırma korkusu yaşıyorsunuz
şimdi bakın
2000'li yıllarda Devlet Bahçeli bir
konuşma yapmıştı demişti ki televizyonda
çocuklar püskebitleri görüyorlar ve anne
bana niye almıyorsun bizde niye yok
diyor diye
yani etmişti bakın
püskevi yani hiç öyle zengin çok işte
maliyetli bir şey değil 90'lı yıllarda
televizyonda Bir sucuk reklamı çıkardı
denirdi ki ya çocuklarımız alamıyorlar
lütfen Hani sucuk reklamları
yayınlamasınlar ritüele şikayet yağdı
bugün Instagram'da bir genç Instagram'a
girdiği anda saat 11'de aç Nusret
ettiriyor orada Nusret altından etleri
parçalıyor ve bu mesafede görüyorum ben
tamam dolapta bir tane yoğurt Duruyor
böyle boynu
adam böyle Kuzu etinden altına bulanmış
Eti benim o saatte başka ne var
Instagram'a giren genç bakın şunu
görüyor klima sonra dağlarına tırmanan
işte İşini bırakıp bodrumda
domatesçiliğe başlayan çok mutlu
insanlar görüyor Ve o kadar çok görüyor
ki bunu sürekli sürekli bunu görüyor
şimdi dayıların anlamadığı yere gelelim
dayıların mutluluk baremi arkadaşlar 1
ile 5 arasındaydı
ve onlar 3 birimler ya da 2 birimlerdi
ve diyorlar telefonum olsa işte
kütüphanem olsa ne
bileyim çok iyi olurdu
[Müzik]
Siz 15 birim şarttasınız bu dayıya göre
ama sizin mutluluk vereminizi Instagram
gibi uygulamalar 200'e çıktı o yüzden
mutsuz hissediyoruz Çünkü herkes çok
mutlu
bu hafta güzel bir anınızı paylaşın
burada bir arkadaşımız diyecek ki ya ben
kötüyüm herhalde Çünkü Hiçbirimiz
üzüldüğünüz ağladığınız hallerinizi
koymuyorsunuz internete Allah'ım gittik
Vallaha ama iğrenç geçti
buna diyen yok
Hepiniz çok mutlu al paylaşıyorsunuz O
yüzden Herkeste bir yetişememe hali var
Game Of thrones'u da izlemeliyim balata
da gitmeliyim bilmem ne de yapmayın
Demek ki mutluluk böyle bir şey mutluluk
böyle bir şey değil bizi mutluluk
peşinde koşturuyorlar huzur peşinde
değil
Biz sürekli mutluluk peşinde koşuyoruz
gençlere sürekli bunu pompalıyoruz bunu
alırsan mutlu olursun bunu
yaparsamayacaksınız Bu arada yani öyle
olmayacak o iş medair Hoca
sorarsınız da özellikle şimdi bu
püskevit meselesi
yani Ama hedefler Ulaş mutluluğu
anlaşılması gereken hedeflerde çok
yüksek şimdi öyle olduğu için de herkes
fotoğraf çekme derdinde ve paylaşma
derdinde kimse carp DM demiyor kimse bu
teyze gibi anı yaşamıyor herkes çekelim
ve paylaşalım Ben de oradaydım Yavuz
Yiğit de oradaydım O gün o fotoğrafı
çektirdim Bakın ben de onunla
birlikteydim deme peşinde kimse manaya
odaklanamıyoruz bu dönemde
ve bizi zehirliyor bu üç tane mesele o
sebeple büyük çoğunuz buraya gitmek
istiyor değil mi Doğu Ekspresi biletine
dost duxby'si bu telesk sonrasında desek
ki bir kişiye işte Doğu ekspresine
göndeririz herkes daha çok güzel falan
Çünkü bu öyle bir sunum yapıldı ki Doğu
ekspresindeki harika bir yerdir yani
Kars'a gitmek ama bilet bulunmayacak
kadar da değildir ya Bundan 15 senede
deseydim ki hocam Kars'a bilet
bulamayacaksınız kimseye inanmazdı bugün
bilet bulunamıyor biletler böyle Kara
borsa çağında yaşıyoruz o sebeple
büyüklerin gençlerde anlamadığı şey
bugünkü imkanları büyükler bir nimet
zannediyor
imkanlar o nimetle birlikte bu çocukları
sırtındaki çok büyük
psikolojilerine çok büyük yük bunu
çözebilmek için
gençleri aşağılamak küçümsemek
dertlerini küçümsemek Bu sorunun cevabı
olmayacak Bu çocukların gözlerinin içine
bakmak bu gençlerin gözlerinin içine
bakmak bu dertleri bugüne çözmek Bugün
de çözmek gerekir Hz Ali'nin çok
sevdiğim bir sözü var çocuklarınızı
Kendi çağınıza değil onların
büyüğü o sebeple Bizler büyükler için
söylüyorum bunu izleyen dinleyecek olan
gençlik yöneticiler için söylüyorum bu
gençlerin sorunlarını anlamadan
problemlerini
daha fazla için okul dışı kitabında
bunları anlattım Çok teşekkür ederim
geldiğinizde dinlediğiniz için
[Alkış]